- [Instructor] We are told,
"Select the two fractions
"that are greater than one."
So pause this video and
see if you can figure out
which two of these fractions
are greater than one.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
And so, the main realization here,
the main thing to pay attention
to is how the numerator
relates to the denominator.
When we are at one, they're
equal to each other.
For example, one is equal to one whole.
I guess you could write
it that way, one oneths.
Or you could also write it as two halves,
is also equal to three thirds,
is also equal to four fourths.
We could go on and on.
If you want it in terms of sixths,
one would be equal to six sixths.
And so, if whatever we have up here
is larger than the denominator,
so if we have seven sixths
or if we were to have maybe five fourths.
Notice, the numerator is
larger than denominator.
These are all situations
when we are greater than one.
And all the situations where the numerator
is less than the denominator,
so example one half
or nine 11ths, or 10 11ths,
these are all situations
where we are less than one.
All of this is less than one.
So let's look over here.
Four is less than six.
Four sixths is less than six sixths.
Remember is the same thing as six sixths.
So this is not greater than one,
so I would not select that.
Nine fourths, well
that's definitely larger
than four fourths.
That is greater than one
and once again our numerator
is larger than our denominator,
so we know that we are greater than one.
So I will select that one.
And then we see again five halves.
Two halves is equal to one,
so five halves is
definitely greater than one.
So I like that one as well.
And notice, five is greater than two
and then we are already know
we picked our two choices,
but we can look at the other ones.
Seven is less than eight,
so seven eighths is
less than eight eighths,
so this is less than one.
And three thirds, we've
already talked about it,
that's equal to one.
So I like those two choices.
Let's do another example that tackles it
a little bit of a different way.
It says, "What, which
fraction could represent
"Point A on the number line?"
And Point A is here.
They don't tell us a lot about Point A,
but all they do tell us by
looking at the number line
is that Point A is less than one.
So which of these, another
way to think about it,
is less than one?
All right, in order for
it to be less than one
the numerator has to be
less than the denominator.
Here our numerator is
greater than the denominator.
Seven fourths is definitely
larger than four fourths.
Remember, four fourths is equal to one.
This right over here I could
rewrite as four fourths.
And so, seven fourths is
going to be someplace,
seven fourths is going to
be someplace over there.
So this is definitely not our choice.
Two halves, well once again
that's the same thing as one.
That's right over there.
So that's not our choice.
What about five eighths?
Well, five eighths,
the numerator is less
than the denominator.
Eight eighths is equal to one,
so that's that point again.
So five eighths would
be to the left of that.
So that could be Point A.
So I like that choice.